42% FOREIGN
Y.
PRESIDENT BIDEN SAT D IN THE EXE
IMPUNITY TO TALK ABOUT THE U
OFL NUSTAKES GET THEAL
N BE SHA END I
ARMAGEDDON.S A RATIONAL ACTOR,
IFINK HE THINKS HE WAS GOING
TO BWETHE HOME OF KYIV, AND HE .
HE TOTALLY MCA
I HAVE NO INTENTIOOF MEETING
IF HE CAME TO MET THE G20 AND
SAID I WANT TO TALK ABOUT RELEA
BA, ING E ABOUOIL.I WENT ABOUT
CONSEQUENCES FOR WHAT DONE WITHE
PRESIDENT BIDEN SAIDBAD
DECISIONHAS BEENRPO U S
THIS AN IMANES>> I DON'T THINK H
R .NG AND PUTIN IGOK DOWN.
YO RIGHT.
RIOAL.
N , GEOPOLITICAL, I  AS JOE
THD I DISCSED IT AT
E GIS, IT'S
ENTIIFFERENT THAAL
ANCONTINUES TO BE DIFFERENT
DESPITE ALL THE SECKS.
ATIONAL,
RATIONALAYG. HAND, HE DOES
HE DEDG TO DO IT.
NN
THAT'S NOT PAR HISNAA MA
E HA, Y WAYS HE DETERMINED
HAVE AINER THAT WIN
MA RATIOL ANIRRATIONAL.  OYOINT
PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID HE
ABOURINER,. PUT OF
THIS. GN
AS INTERESTING, RSIFOREIGN MIN
SAID IN
AT MAY CONSIDE
SO IES SEEARE CH OTHER SIGNALS
ARE NOT GOING E UP THEIR
.
SO TO SPE
NOTEAT RANDOMLYUNNINGO ERR SOM?
>>DOES
I ACTUALLY THINKE NTING LOTI, E
SWIRLED ALL THE OTHER ARE
NOW, NOW YO FROBO THE ROUND M.
CETO THA THE
ATMOSPHERE IN THE COUNTRY.
TTIN, I
THINK IT WASF JUNE, I GOIN, IT O
ALL THE AU ITALIAN
AND FRENCH, TH CHINESE
SIGNS OF ANY KINUG
CONTINUE, AN
OR AER WAR WILZZLE T IN A, I EY
NEE SOMETHING.
AND THEN EVERYK IT WAS
TTING WOE URNINGDICTATORIAL.
FOR E, A EDITOPEACE PRIZE AND T
D
TWO WEEKS LATER IT CLOSED.ASETS
E PRETTY MUCH
READY FOMO
THD THATE IN A WWAR IS ELSEWHER.
WH THEY SAY ISUPPORT
PUTIN,T'NO
LEAVE US ALONE DIROW LHI DAYS A
GEORGERWL, 2022.US BREATHE
ENALKS ABOUT THE
HISTORALURE, WOXYMOR, DERSTAND
FUEING
TIE
RHET FKR VERLLIAN, WS
NORANC